hi everyone our topic of the day is
mindful testing balancing test coverage
and maintenance before we dive into the
topic a quick introduction to us my name
is Rita Lee and I am an engineering
manager in Google clouds engineering
productivity organization hello everyone
my name is shadi I'm an engineering
manager in Google cloud engineering
productivity organization
so today we will be talking to you about
what is mindful testing we also would
like to talk to you about why mindful
testing is an important concept that you
could practice in your organization and
what benefits that would give you we
will talk about five tips on how you can
practice mindful testing along the way
we'll talk about various tools and
processes we use at Google and
especially in Google Cloud to apply
mindful testing to our products so
reading from the definition in the
Oxford Dictionary mindfulness is the
quality or state of being conscious or
aware of something so what is mindful
testing to understand this let's talk
about integration testing to which the
concept of mindful testing applies the
most we know that integration tests are
a complex system we know that we have to
constantly balance trade-offs between
too many tests and too few tests when it
comes to integration tests if you have
too many integration tests you may have
great coverage of your product but your
release life cycle might be slow if you
have too few tests you may be releasing
very quickly but at the cost possibly of
reliability and velocity of your system
we also know that tests have a life
cycle
if you want to add a new feature you may
need to add new tests if you change your
deprecated feature you may need to
change your deprecated the test that you
have so in summary what we believe is
test can help you improve product
quality but only through thoughtful care
so going back to mindful testing how do
we define that we define it as the art
and science of writing and maintaining
just the right amount of tests that
gives you enough product coverage why my
testing there are four reasons that we
would like to present to you about why
mindful testing is important
the first one is reliability you want to
find those bugs before your customers do
you also want to make sure that you are
delivering a stable dependable product
to your customers mindful testing can
help you provide that reliability our
second reason is time to market if you
want faster time to market for your
features in your product
mindful testing can help you achieve
that with a good balance between too
many and too few tests
the third reason is technical death and
reducing that and the fourth reason is
developer productivity both of these the
third and fourth reason are great
reasons to make sure your engineers are
happier and who doesn't want that so
hopefully we've convinced you that
mindful testing is an interesting
concept that can help you in your
products overall let's talk about 5 tips
for mindful testing we will present to
you 5 useful tips to achieve mindful
testing that we continuously try to
adopt for our teams and our products
here to start with listen to your tests
when they fail they are telling you
something very important now to listen
to your tests and be able to take action
when they fail you need to start with a
setup that has high signal-to-noise
ratio at Google we do this by ensuring
that every failure type has an owner and
we have routing tools that automatic
route failures correctly to the
corresponding team for example a GCE
integration and to end test failure
could be routed to the control plane the
virtualization the guest the last or the
kernel T and so on also we want to take
immediate action when failures happen we
achieve this by setting response as
allows to our test failures and we do
this by having bug master rotations from
different teams to keep an eye on the
bills when they fail we also have a
philosophy off roll back first and
investigate later we have play books
that developers follow to make the job
easier in investigating those failures
in addition we need to follow up on
large-scale tests breakages with
post-mortems the post-mortem analysis
look into how could we prevent such
breakages from happening again and how
could we shift our testing to the left
and also our philosophy here is right
the smallest test pass
we try to apply the same rigor of
production outages to our test outages
especially the integration and
end-to-end tests help you test stay
healthy they need to help developing
good habits the first habit we try to
develop is running on hermetic test
infrastructure versus non-aromatic one a
familial test environments allow your
tests to run in isolation be repeatable
and easier to debug here this is an
example of kind which is kubernetes in a
docker as a system in a box test
infrastructure it enables you to run
hermetic tests and it allows you to run
integration tests for kubernetes is
fuser anthos application the environment
here would be isolated with no external
dependencies and be completely if a
mirror we also want to ensure that tests
clean up after themselves now this is
needed
mostly when we shared the test
environment across different tests we
know that setting up a hermetic if a
made of test environment is not possible
for every single test suite either
because of the coast or because of the
complexity of systems so in those cases
where we are sharing a test environment
across different test Suites we need to
make sure that we clean up every every
single test run and we keep the shared
environment in a good state to enable
compute engine tests to clean up after
themselves effectively we created tools
for as project rental service this
allows GC developers to use few test
projects to run their integration tests
as a test starts to run they would go
and rent a project out of a pool of
projects they would use their project to
do any testing needed and then when
they're done they would return the
project to the service now the service
is responsible of cleaning up the
project deleting all resources and
setting the project back to a clean
slate which could be reused again for
other testing this
separates the test from the clean up
needed and guarantees that the cleanup
is done effectively and correctly we
also want to invest in root causing and
debugging tools no matter what
environment we run again either if it's
her medical shared environment we need
good root causing and debugging tools
for example tools like cloud debugger
can help you significantly in debugging
your cloud application the content is to
discipline your test with respect
because sometimes they will try your
patience our strategy for having healthy
tests the cornerstone of this is to
manage flakiness let's talk a little bit
about why managing flakiness is so
important well consider a marker
services architecture with about 40
critical components if each of those
components is only point to 6 percent
flaky you would still get an overall
environment flakiness of 10 percent to
get an overall environment flakiness of
about 1.5 percent which is a good
standard for being able to release
products quickly you would still need
each component to have just 0.03 8%
flakiness hopefully this shows you why
managing thickness is critical for us we
manage flakiness with two approaches one
is that we track flakiness numbers
really closely so we know when and where
and how lateness shows up in our
integration tests here is an example of
a graph that one of our metrics tool
generated as you can see here it shows a
90 day trend for not only how much
flakiness is present in our systems but
also the number of test targets that
were affected by display keys so this is
an example of this and many other
metrics we track around flakiness to
help us understand how to combat it
better we also invest in long term flick
nice pictures this is an example of a
before-and-after from a flakiness fix it
as you can see the before has a lot more
inconsistency at Lincoln s while the
after looks a lot more consistent in
terms of the test results we see their
fixes are a long-term tradition at
Google where teams will set aside time
from their regular work for up to a week
or more sometimes to focus on
engineering excellence things and
flakiness is a very popular tip to focus
on so in summary we discipline our tasks
with managing flakiness tracking it and
making sure that we prioritize long term
fixes teacher test independence so you
don't have to turn to their needs open
we really want to lower the maintenance
cost of all our tests maintaining the
test is very expensive so we start with
proper capacity planning we need to
provide adequate resources to run our
tests quickly and correctly at Google we
do this by taking inventory of all our
test resources needed once a year to
make sure that the existing test could
run properly and also to ensure that we
have enough capacity during the coming
year for additional tests the graph here
shows you why capacity planning is
important and measuring is important as
well here we could see that there is an
amount of unused
resources for running that single test
we could reduce the resources allocated
for that test so that we could run
either more tests or we could increase
the parallelism of our testing and
reduce the time to finish the tests
right once running anywhere is our
philosophy to get the maximum out of
your tests especially when you're
dealing with integration and to end
testing this allows you to run tests
against different test environments and
to validate them quicker anthos is an
example of such an infrastructure that
follows the water paradigm it allows you
to run your application and the tests
either on Prem
or on the public cloud at Google we also
invest a lot in smart test
infrastructure for example machine
learning based pre subnets
that run fewer targeted tests instead of
the whole test Suites based on different
signals especially from the changeless
being submitted this will reduce the
amount of resources needed to run on
that at the same time keeping a high
confidence of our test coverage and the
signal also automatic capacity planning
where we could automatically reduce the
resources needed her test run and reuse
those resources for other runs we need
to spend a lot of time with our tests
and our test infrastructure we start
with proper maintenance and here I'm
talking about maintaining our critical
user journeys and tracking feature
coverage for our testing to give you an
example the GCE live migration feature
presented here is mapped to certain Cu
J's that we have test to cover those
tests are tracked and we have automatic
tooling to track the coverage based on
the Cu J's for DC this helps us keep
focus on where testing is needed the
most and in preventing regressions in CU
j test coverage we know that CJ testing
specially integration enter and are very
costly and we want to make the best use
of our testing we also need to keep an
eye on upgrading our test infrastructure
to new technologies that could allow us
to run tests faster or debug them or
maintain them better at Google we do
this by having core teams responsible of
common test infrastructure that is used
across different Google teams for
example we have a common system
integration test framework that allows
us to benefit from any improvements that
team does on that test infrastructure
and allow us to move quickly to new
technologies we also want to look into
adding more test coverage and test
features as we see appropriate and here
we're focusing on follow ups on
production outages where we do an
analysis
on what testing is needed to prevent
those outages from happening again and
also based on customer issues all on
test outages themselves as I said big
test altitude could lead to more testing
different pieces in the pipeline
especially moving left to the
development cycle also we need to look
into deleting and duplicating our tests
this is needed when features are
deprecated or when critical user
journeys priorities are changed and by
that we need to keep an eye on the
testing that we're running and applicate
them or change the flow wheel on them so
those were the five tips that we wanted
to share with you we have a couple of
key takeaways for you from our top the
first one is that mindful testing can
help change your organization's culture
to focus on healthy and regularly cared
for tests the second takeaway we have
for you is that mindful testing will
really help you get more return on
investment from your tests we wanted to
give a shout out to two talks from cloud
next 2019 both of these have a deep dive
into the different concepts that we
talked about today and they also talked
about how you can apply these concepts
and thereby mindful testing too by using
the different products we have available
on the Google cloud platform
so do check them out that's all we have
to share with you today thank you so
much for listening to our talk
thank you all for listening to us please
give us feedback on how you apply
mindful testing and your organization
and if you find these tips useful thank
you